there are very few prominent black
cosplayers I definitely feel like a
minority within a minority sometimes
cosplays literally stands for a costume
play
so with individuals who dress up in
costume you get to embody the characters
it's almost like making an action figure
of yourself
my name is drew Barnett by day I'm a web
content manager but by night I'm
Deadshot for me cosplay is a creative
outlet I'm not an artist I can't draw
but I love to build I love to craft do
things with my hands each costume is art
piece cosplayers know me as a blurred
vision blurred literally stands for
black nerd within the cosplay community
in general I feel accepted but majora
characters of cosplay were originally
Caucasian characters I definitely feel
the racial tension even my flash cosplay
people thought at first I was the
reverse-flash
I'm quitting not like that character you
think I am so why assume the villain
it's really disconcerting when you love
a character but because you don't
actually look like the character people
won't kind of judge you for that for me
and the people that I associated with
it's more about what you love and if you
love the character that characters
tom books in general are starting to
push characters in the direction of
being more diverse
whether it be gay straight black white
whatever it is they're changing the old
guard of heroes to a more modern version
of them so you should be reflection of
like we're siding looks like today
hopefully in the future that actually
changes people's metallics where these
characters and what you can be it's a
powerful thing when you can look at a
character and go that's me it gives you
the idea that you actually do anything
if you actually can identify with
someone that can do anything
you